what's up what's up tyra banks here I'm
at BuzzFeed and we are going to have a
staring contest there are three rules
whoever blinks first loses talking or
trash-talking it's totally allowed most
importantly no one knows they're having
a staring contest with me let's do this
okay this time written to build it are
you kidding me
okay I want to do this
yeah it's a lot I love it oh my gosh
well these tears are part like wow this
is how vain / oh my gosh where the onion
is thank you mother
yes it's a llama it's like you're - how
old are you 36
no you're like 47 cuz you're a black
person yeah yeah basically 63 yeah
exactly yeah I understand yeah
alright let's get it okay what do you
miss most about doing runway shows what
I miss the most about doing the shows is
the walk honey yes I made sure that I
had a signature walk it's important to
have something that even if you were in
silhouette and people can't see you but
they can see your outline that they know
it's you and then I used to do this
thing with my eyes alright walk so I
miss the law oh my goodness hello hi e
Emily that maizing amazing yes you are
oh no I'm supposed to go
hi bling-bling it's so nice to meet nice
to meet you anyway I love your wings
see you do those every day every day are
so good I think I'm supposed to ask you
this question okay okay so which new
models are you loving right now oh my
god
ducky ducky dang she don't look real
she no she's right it's like she she
just looks like a drawing nobody beats
Tyra oh what a mess I've had hair okay
one two three
staring contest with me in fashion
are you that's why you know that because
you're like iconic thank you no thank
you
all right I have a question for you so
what current TV shows are you obsessed
with right now oh I love ozark I love
harlots and then that Julia Roberts fun
what's that one called Oh the Amazon one
I freaked ha having homecoming that is I
hope you watch it it's good I like it
calls you it's so good you should watch
it eyes closed yeah 1 2 3 so I have two
photos in my hands only one person can
be chosen
[Laughter]
you totally won and you trash-talk like
she was like oh surprise not really I'm
not sure they're not shook it it was are
you what's one characteristic or hobby
of yours that might surprise people oh I
love to lick chips maybe now if you said
that during the staring contest so one
time my partner on America's Next Top
Model I'm at the judging table that
Ashley Graham is here juelia does their
law roaches there I'm looking chips
you're about to decide on who the
winners I'm licking jittery living and
I'm putting them in a butt and we could
just put them in a little Bowl he comes
over he's like so let's talk about this
oh you guys go away
two three oh my you bling I did
I'm just whack alright hmm which style
trying to you wish would go away and
which one do you want to make a comeback
the style trend that I wish would go
away is 13 year old little girls and
short shorts okay I'm like really and
it's like you're in the mood nice great
are they great and the one that I wish
would come back dynasty shoulder really
I love them I wear them all the time and
I just a big shoulder I love a big
shoulder yeah that's funny so the thing
about the booty shirts kaziri literally
some supermodel I used to be I've
retired that dude oh boy oh my god
you're smiling so much again oh my god
how do you balance competing with other
models and building friendships with
them oh interesting question yes there's
only so many jobs to go around right
yeah I had some friends and some people
that just weren't very nice and I tried
to stay away from them as far as I could
oh gosh I'm so nervous
one two
for like a month Kirby enthusiasm no
smizing the eyes burning yet a little
bit my Rachel is no joke
I have a question what was one of your
favorite behind-the-scenes moments from
life-size - well earlier on in the film
I really wanted to get to know Francia
who's also the other star in life-size -
and we went to a spa and this we got
into the jacuzzi
with towels and then I think we put the
towels down but there was time to get
out and there were no towels and I was
like okay I guess I'm bonding with my
co-star because we're gonna be butt
naked up in hill from that moment she
does like my boobs cuz like she saw my
booty I had to I had to I had to I had
to oh my god gorgeous it was here oh
there oh yeah happy dance yeah I can
tell Jeremy I can tell you it like that
but not professionally I don't you like
a comedian you have something what are
you doing here what he's quitting it's
not it's done I just gotta you know just
quit uh what a & TM photo shoot why did
you say it's so slow like didn't know
what the show is good man t I'm nervous
it was an acronym
what a NTS yeah you got photo shoot do
you think is the most iconic snakes
snakes season one the girls had snakes
wrapped around their necks I was there
right there helping them pose and I will
never forget Robin manning her very
first plus-size what I like to call fear
see role model on top model she had her
snake and she was like Jesus Jesus James
us like she just was talking to the Lord
just trying to get it together she was
freaking out she was crying but
something overcame her I
to her photographer talked to her put
her mind somewhere else or even closer
to God hmm well that concludes my
staring contest here at BuzzFeed I think
I failed miserably but it doesn't matter
because I'm still the queen of smile see
you later
[Music]